and then start okay uh welcome to the
ddps seminar everyone before we
introduce our invited speaker let's go
over some rules and Logistics first of
all please mute yourself during the talk
but if you have a question you cannot
mute and ask questions during during the
talk or you can use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in between HSN at the end second to
today's ddps stamina is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed and finally The
Talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel
that's it let me briefly introduce our
speaker today it's an honor to host Dr
Eleni tetsi who is an associate
professor and chair of structural
mechanics and monitoring at the
department of
civil and environmental and geomatic
Engineering at eth Zurich our research
interests include the field of
structural Health monitoring and
structural Dynamics and intelligent
data-driven assessment of Engineering
Systems today Eleni will present an
exciting topic which is training and
model Discovery for engineered systems
I'm sure we will hear an exciting
exciting talk today but before I pass
the button to Eleni let me ask a couple
of questions just to get to know you
better learning and make this seminar
someone in inform in promo all right are
you ready yes go ahead all right the
first question is obviously you are
passionate about structural Health
monitoring and structural Dynamics in
general is there any moment in your life
when you realize that wow this is it
this is the field I would like to commit
my career onto this field do you have
that moment
hmm I you know a moment of realization
that's a good question I should explain
you know monitoring for me was something
new uh to discover when I came to the us
at the Columbia University to work at
the engineering uh civil engineering and
Engineering mechanics department on this
theme until then I followed the more
traditional civil engineering studies
that were not so much into the concept
of data system identification
exploitation of such Technologies let's
say at that point in time
and so it was already something new and
exciting which sparked my interest from
the beginning of my doctoral studies but
I think the realization came near the
third year of my studies when I actually
got to go on the Manhattan Bridge which
is an iconic structure in in New York
and you know the Chloe sensors sensing
instruments ourselves together with the
group of my advisor at the time
Professor Andrew Smith and actually you
know gather the data that was to be used
for something practical for something
that I could see a tangible outcome and
at that point I realized okay this is
something I would like to do and it's
not just about maybe Theory which is on
its own exciting but it's possibly
something that could help me effectively
make a difference or you know at least
uh
uh seed applied in a way that makes
sense and I think that's what made uh
made me more excited and that's when I
decided to get into this in a bit more
serious or academic I guess manner
very nice so you do have that moment I
feel like this was it for me that's true
but you can never
things form the government
the accumulation of several smaller
experiences that somehow adapt to
something but maybe the realization yeah
could depend down to a moment I suppose
all right the second question which is
the last question
you are now serving as vice president of
the European Academy of wind energy
that's a such a big job sounds like how
did it how did it happen would you mind
sharing a brief story about it
um yes so maybe this is closely related
to what the experience I described
before
so for me applications in Wind
engineering came rather uh it's not that
recently but I think it was not until
2015 actually or 14 rather on the
occasion of a grant that I was writing
that is equivalent to a career Grant in
the US it's a New York City starting
Grant in Europe
um where you know the idea was to
suggest a topic that was new and bold
something that hasn't really been tried
before and at the time the structural
monitoring of wind energy structures was
not really something that was heavily
pursued not much work existed from the
point of view of uh methods that
exploited structural monitoring data
structural mechanics models in tandem
with data and so
so the approval of that ground I began
to become I sort of entered this realm
of wind energy structures which was
again new to me at the time but I also
came slowly to know the different
colleagues to work more closely with
colleagues in Europe and eventually
entered this European Academy of wind
energy where many of the colleagues that
work in the wind energy domain
participate to represent their
institutions and that's how I became a
member of that society and now I'm the
vice president of the society at the
moment representing the field of
structural monitoring and representing
it and actually a field that is in
itself very very broad so we have
colleagues from the domains of control
Power grids electrical engineering uh
civil more traditional or structural
analysis groups and of course fluid
simulation so it's really a very diverse
field that has to somehow work in tandem
for a common goal which is actually the
resilience and the performance design of
these systems and structures so I guess
something new and exciting for me not so
new maybe anymore but certainly remains
exciting through the interdisciplinarity
of the topic so I'm glad to be part of
this Mr Society awesome awesome well you
know the excitement follows some
responsibility I guess so
um yes
this is true especially when these
societies are as diverse but it's also a
pleasure to to work with colleagues from
all these different Origins and uh I
guess skills and interests awesome
awesome all right I will not bother you
with any more questions
um so the floor is yours you can share
your slide and then
um
let me try but I think you mentioned
that we could also take questions during
so that's also welcomed for me awesome
um and I'm going to try and give a small
overview here of the work that we do in
my group the chair of structural
mechanics and monitoring and tth Zurich
on this theme the theme of training and
model Discovery for engineered systems
and you already see a wind turbine there
because it has become or it has grown to
become a substantial portion of what we
deal with but the truth is that our
applications funnier and long uh a
rather broad domain of applications with
a golden thread being this concept of
structural Health monitoring with your
first question allowed me to elaborate
on
instructional Health monitoring from my
point of view can only be conceptualized
as a chain a chain which initiates with
the Gathering and accumulation of data
from different types of sensing sources
offering heterogeneous information of
diverse types in my group we're
particularly interested of in exploding
vibration based signals because often
they are very rich in content and
information and that's also why we um in
the term of social mechanics and
monitoring one of the domains of our
expertise is also structural Dynamics
now what we try to do on the basis of
this accumulated data is to exploit the
information and translate it into
something that is interpretable
something that can be used by Engineers
for their management for the management
of their assets typically in two
configurations the diagnostic
configuration where we try to assess the
condition of the system as is and the
prognostic configuration where we're
interested to learn more or predict
rather the future performance or
remaining useful life of a system
extracting quantifiable indicators that
can guide us to their operational
maintenance and overall management now
of course the translation of data into
something that is Meaningful information
is non-trivial and this is where the
strengths of what we develop comes in or
at least the particular expertise of my
group which which lies in the
exploitation of models that draw from
principles of physics physics
represented in the sense of mechanics or
Dynamics
and where through these models we can
actually maximize the information that
can be drawn from the raw data and after
creating this kind of a Synergy and
trying creating these quantifiable
metrics of system performance we try to
then extend these to the system level so
I spoke earlier when turbines but we're
also interested in trying to understand
performance at the level of the farm or
if the fleet of farms that are operating
or on which we draw data from or if
we're talking about more conventional
civil engineering infrastructure we
would be talking not only about
individual Bridges or Road components
but rather of the transport Network as a
whole as an entity that can be managed
on the basis of flow of data
so these are the elements of the chain
that make up shm but also the chain that
is relevant for us in terms of the
fields that we're active in
so uh as I mentioned before we gather
data from various systems we have a
collaboration with the railway
authorities here in Zurich where we use
sensors mounted on trains or vehicles to
understand the performance not only on
the vehicle Fleet side but also the
traversed infrastructure side we deal
with more traditional civil engineering
applications like the monitoring of
buildings under for example seismic
excitations or the monitoring of bridges
under the different types of loads that
they are exposed to including aging and
slow evolving deterioration forcings
and of course talking about condition
monitoring we also have applications in
the more traditional area of industrial
assets
and of course wind energy structures in
fact it may be interesting to know that
we even own a turbine
so this is a turbine that is not too not
too far from our campus from which we
use as a living lab it's sort of a toy
in the sense that we try to use an
experiment with for testing and
verifying our methodologies
uh and so I will focus in this talk
um as the title somehow hints on the
aspect of modeling or the inference of
models and how this can be used in a way
that makes sense or maximizes our
understanding of a system which is what
we would like to do at the end of the
day but before I do that I always think
it interesting to also point out what we
can do on the basis of pure uh
exploitation of data without necessarily
trying to include some knowledge of the
physics that underpins our problem and
to do this I will show you again an
interesting application again here at
the farm actually level
from wind energy monitoring so in this
case we're trying to see we can produce
a data-driven model that can capture the
effect of wakes which is actually the
effect that this front turbines will
have as you see it here this shadow that
is created on the basis of how the wind
is
oriented within a site which has
implications for the downstream turbines
not only in terms of the power that they
produce but also in terms of the loads
that they experience and therefore the
fatiguing of these turbines and
eventually given their condition
through the accumulation of such wake
effects now if you would like to model
this with physics the program could
become quite complicated and there are
models that try to approximate the
problem but of course there's no
guarantee that they reflect exactly what
is the condition on site so to tackle
this issue we actually use the data that
we monitor
um that we draw from monitoring of this
turbine so data at the level of the Hub
that give us information about the mean
wind speed and our orientation as well
as the power production but also moment
data that have has to do with the loads
that are experienced by these turbines
and we try to develop a data-driven
model in this case which admits as an
input the mean wind field conditions as
you would gather them from a
meteorological Mast and translate them
into what is the prediction of the wind
that will affect the individual turbines
and by extension what are actually
engineering critical quantities like the
wind deficit that would be experienced
by this turbines but depending on the
orientation of this mean wind and the
way in which we did that here has no
physics actually it draws from the
learning on the rich collected data over
a large period of time and we use
conditional variational autoencoders to
create this generated model in the
Continental conditioning was of course
done on these mean wind conditions which
is essentially what defines the output
and the prediction of these models so
this is nice because this is something
that reflects the reality it's still a
model it's still a generated model but
of course and we didn't have to use any
complex physics-based
um information that could probably also
take a long time to compute uh at the
same time it gives us information on
critical quantities in this case we can
also compute damage equivalent loads
which from the engineering perspective
is important for judging us to the
operation of these systems but the issue
is we cannot always get away with
neglecting physics and it's great when
we have these loads of data at least of
that form as I showed you for turbines
the scada information that ensure this
knowledge on wind conditions but there
exist quantities that are not so easy to
infer or to understand just by
straightforwardly looking at the raw
data
uh one such
aspect is the Dynamics that may be
underlying the system and this is
something we're interested to know
because it could actually
um Define its performance and so as I
mentioned before we typically are in the
business of collecting Dynamics data or
vibration based data usually by mounting
acceleration or saying gauge
type of sensors here you see an
installation okay it's a graphic but
it's a typical installation we also have
on real systems an array of sensors for
example on a tower of a wind turbine
from which vibration response would be
collected and here what we would like to
do as an interim stage where we try to
bias a bit on the knowledge of you know
the Dynamics that is governed in the
system we try to represent this by using
appropriate time series based
representations again they are data
driven but within them they carry the
structure of the expected Dynamics I
will describe a bit on this in what
follows so in this case we're trying to
describe our Dynamics with parameterized
models and at the same time we know that
the performance of a system over the
long period of time is dependent on the
influencing environmental and
operational variables again the mean
wind field direction or speed which
could change over time it could be the
temperature and humidity conditions the
wave loadings that are seasonal and so
in order to have a holistic model that
can capture the condition or rather the
response of the system over an extended
period of time we try to build these
dependence models which are really by
component models one part to take on the
response of the system that is measured
in the short time and a dependence model
to take on
the influence of external agents or
these environmental and operational
variables onto the response of the
system there are many ways to achieve
this dependence and I'm listing here
only some of these at least the ones
that we have worked with but at the end
of the day what is important is that we
have we can manage to construct
hierarchical models which are predicted
models of the quantities that we measure
and which we can then use as a means to
create a conditional assessors of the
system that can then signal us to
possible damage
now I want to say here why I mentioned
before that this data-driven models that
are time history essentially uh type of
Time series types of type of models
actually uh encode within them some of
the Dynamics of the system and this is
because if we have a non-linear system
we know that we could approximate it by
using
compact parametric representations of
that auto regressive type which are
particularly suited for non-linear
models this would be the nonlinear Auto
regressive class of models which you see
listed here and similarly for
non-stationary systems we could have
corresponding parametric representations
like a discrete wavelet transform or for
time varying systems which is really
what our wind turbines are we could use
a Time varying Auto regressive class of
models to encode the Dynamics that we
expect in the model that we try to use
to approximate the system and this is
quite convenient because when you want
to have a holistic representation and it
dependence on influencing agents A
parametric model gives a natural means
to do so because these coefficients or
parameters of the model can be
conditioned on these influencing agents
and this is one way to do this actually
the expression that you see here is
through a polynomial chaos expansion
it's basically an input output surrogate
stochastic surrogate which gives the
dependence of these coefficients as the
and environment changes here is a
practical example of this unreal
measurements so this is an acceleration
time history from a tower of wind
turbine one of the turbines that we
monitor the specific one is in Germany
actually and here you see the
spectrogram that would correspond to
this plot in the Contour now in the
spectrogram through the intensity of the
colors it is clear that the frequencies
of this dynamic system are not constant
so we're not talking here about the
stationary system a system which under
traditional system identification tools
would be easy to understand through what
we call operational model analysis
methods but rather a system that is time
wiring and where a time-wiring model
such as a Time Value motor regressive
model as I mentioned before could be
used to track the evolution of the
Dynamics and this is what we did here
this is what you see superimposed
through these blue curves that are
really able to track the evolution of
the Dynamics in the short short time 10
minute window now the problem when we
collect our data is that of course if I
look at another 10 minute window with
another mean speed of the wind or Min
orientation of the wind this portrait
would likely change it would change
because it's conditioned to this
external agents and this is actually
something that we can take on through
the dependent structure so a gaussian
process or a polynomial case exposure
level and neural network model could be
used to express this dependence and
to reflect the evolution of the Dynamics
of a longer period of time for example
here you see the modulation over a
period of a month the conditioning is
done on data that is collected and
that's the nice thing about wind energy
wind turbine structures that we
traditionally collect this supervisory
control and data acquisition scada
information which give us a 10 minute
average data on wind direction speed
power temperature and many more
parameters and this is what we condition
on and if we can do that then we can
train for a sufficient period of time
our hierarchical model and then use it
as a predictor and understand the
deviation between what we predict and
what it is we measured of course there
will be outliers which have to admit the
robust outlier analysis and statistical
analysis so that we can then classify
the alarms that we receive or rather the
indication the indicators that we
calculate as in the green region so
operating operating as expected in
normal conditions in the red region so
in known environmental conditions we
receive alarms so this means we have to
act or we have to signal for repair or
intervention on our system or we receive
alarms which are actually outside of the
regular um
thresholds of our environmental essay
conditions and this is what we would
issue as an orange alarm which means
that there's something off but it could
be off because we are in a new
environment and this is something we
have to treat with further analysis
so in structural Health monitoring and
because we're in close collaboration
often with operators and Engineers we
like to present these red red number
green type of alarms to the
um to let's say the stakeholders and
this is something that they're more
comfortable with that they understand
more so than just a plot without Liars
let's say and one step further we can
even help them to localize damage up to
a degree for example this is something
that we have done on a bridge structure
which you see here it's a bridge in
Switzerland which we controllably
damaged with different scenarios that we
inflicted ourselves so that we can know
where damage is located at and we showed
that by using a network of sensors now
not looking at individual sensors but at
the changes with respect to how the
sensors are placed it is possible to a
degree to also localize perhaps the
damage
and of course this will depend depends
on the density of the central Network
and a few more configurational aspects
but what it tells us is that we are
quite successful up to this point in
diagnosing damage understanding if it
exists and maybe where it is
but if we just want to stick to the data
we cannot do more than that so we cannot
prognose what happens next or how longer
our system can go for without actually
experiencing a critical failure so the
moment we want to go a step further we
maintain the data on its own is actually
not enough and this is the point where
in our analysis it is important to bring
in an engineering model a model that
goes beyond the purely data driven
representation and the diagnostic
capabilities that brings in the physics
that can help us in a sense extrapolate
or understand how the system can perform
all the while being updated by the data
reflecting our system as is so this kind
of a concept of merging physics and
Engineering intuition and models with
data is the hybrid approach to modeling
is what allows us to go to produce this
so-called twins twins that are actually
interactive that somehow close the loop
of communication between the actual
physical system and the virtual um
mirror or the virtual instance that we
are creating since there is always this
communication flow that is ensured by
the by the data
uh precisely because this interaction is
important in our group we pay particular
attention to models that can compute
fast compute ideally in real time so
that we can ensure that we have a
connection between the two
systems the digital and the physical
system always and without interruption
but to do this we have to ensure that
the computational tool of our models has
to be low a task which is actually
non-trivial and on which I would like to
actually focus on so let me actually go
directly here how we can fuse data and
physics-based models for learning
monitoring and training and physically
do so in real time
now the reason why this is uh not an
easy task is not only because of the
complexity of the models which is often
what causes them to uh be slow in terms
of computation but it's also because uh
the effects that we have to account for
are rather complex I already refer to
the aspect of loads that reflect varying
environmental and operational conditions
this could also refer to loads that lead
our systems to experience non-linear
Behavior behavior that is beyond the
easy to compute let's say linear elastic
range in fact most of our loadings are
distributed loading so it's not easy to
model these with just simplified Point
sources and further to this they're also
in most of the cases actually unknown or
even unmeasured and so we have to deal
with all of these intricacies and try to
deliver a predicted model that can cope
with this uncertainty and do so in real
time and the motivation being that we
would like to use this as explained
before for for training applications for
the goal of virtual sensing virtual
sensing is the situation where we wish
to extract information from a system
predicted information beyond the usually
few and sparse locations where we sense
and when we try to construct a proper
digital twin this is very very important
because we should not just be predicting
where we measure but rather in the full
field of this object that we try to
monitor
um and of course the downstream tasks
are numerous including control and
diagnostic aspects that have to do with
maintenance
so I will pick one of these um
tasks to exemplify the framework that we
have set up and for me the most
interesting as I sort of hinted is the
aspect of virtual sensing predict the
response of the system feasibly in real
time in locations that are not measured
or as I come to refer to it basically
achieving everything everywhere all at
once and here's what I mean by this uh
this is our typical monitoring problem
where we have a structural system uh on
which some sensors usually few and spars
are located on this gives us some sort
of measurement information our system is
operating under inputs that we usually
we cannot measure that's the case for a
bridge even for a wind turbine we claim
to know the wind speed and direction but
we don't really know the proper
distributed uh
um force of the wind or the wave as it
is acting on our offshore structure we
have as Engineers some sort of a
priority model that was used to put the
system in place but usually it's not an
accurate model or at least it's not a
model that has been updated necessarily
to reflect the system at its current
point in time and therefore it could
feature unknown parameters additional to
model form uncertainty
and the objective is to extract the
response of the system and this
so-called unknown States is the response
of the system in unmeasured locations
which actually can be numerous so we
would like to do all of this learn the
system predict its response so
everything we would like to do it
everywhere in the full field of the
system and we would like to do it in
real time which is basically all at once
given all of the challenges that I
mentioned earlier
uh so here is how we try to approach the
problem for doing so first of all we
have to reduce the computation of our
engineering models which we wish to
bring in the loop and in our group we
are structural mechanics group so we
have had exposure to and we helped in
development of numerous methods on the
more traditional fronts for um
accelerating computation from the point
of view of fractured plasticity
geometric non-linearity or
multi-structural complex assemblies but
not uh that the majority of these
methods just does not make the cut when
we try to use them as is we need to
boost this kind of a computation and one
way to do this and which is quite
popular in recent years is to do it
through exploitation of the power of
learning through machine or deep
learning formulations uh all the while
though respecting the fact that we have
to learn from physics and Engineering
information
so here's one approach to doing this
this is work by Thomas Simpson one of
the PHD candidates who recently
graduated from our group who tried to
reduce full order complex finite element
models so for civil engineering this is
one of the favorite types of models
usually with a large number of degrees
of freedom which compute in terms of
Dynamics most often quite slow and so
what we did was to train on several
instances of such models
uh or at least on several four things
that are applied onto such models to
extract the so-called latent
representation of this multi-degree of
Freedom system essentially A reduced
order of space where the Dynamics of the
problem lives in and can be
characterized but with the condensed
representation and then we try to apply
the forcing the actual forcing of the
system onto this reduced representation
and we used a numerical integrator or
the equivalent of this for neural
networks which is a in our case an lstm
RNN type of model that takes our
prediction from point time TK to the
next point in time so now we have
computation on reduced coordinates and
we have a possibility to simulate the
system in this reduced space over time
at the same time through the nice
property of Auto encoders we can go back
to our original representation the
original finite element model through
the decoding step and extract the
response over desired system in the full
field in terms of strains or
accelerations in general in terms of the
quantities that we're actually going to
measure eventually from this system uh
simply through this decoding procedure
so this gives a significant acceleration
it allowed us to simulate the systems
that are non-linear so this one it's
actually a non-linear Benchmark that was
defined by our colleagues in Los Alamos
in the U.S a non-linear frame with a
bumper where the response of the system
is challenging to simulate with
traditional system identification tools
that prefer linear systems so here we
simulated the system using this
autoencoder logic showing that the
reduced space that we extract from the
system is actually a type of non-linear
normal mode so they're basically modes
that are independent the majority of the
spectral content of these modes reflects
a specific actually frequency there's
still non-linear representations but
it's actually what empowers us to then
simulate the system using this reduced
representation even at the non-linear
case from a practical Viewpoint we
implemented this Logic on the non-linear
response of Monopoly wind turbines where
non-linearity comes from the behavior of
the soil where you see typical py curves
on the basis of which the engineers wind
Engineers will simulate these models and
that's indeed what our colleagues in
Siemens camessa did they did the actual
simulations on which we trained this
uh autoencoder type of reduced order
model which then replaced their
simulation with high accuracy only it
did so in fragments of a second meaning
it gave us a computational modeling
which can compute in real time and it
can be later combined with data which is
really what we seek to do a bit of an
issue in this reduction approach is that
for most of these configurations uh we
haven't so far discussed the issue of
simulating systems of different
parameters so even in this monopole
structure it's actually a fixed
structure and system but which we
simulate under different types of loads
and we try to accelerate the simulation
for this particular instance but if you
want to have a general model that can
compute over different parameters and
different configurations so different
shapes of the Tower or lengths of the
blades and whatnot we have to compute we
have to construct a so-called parametric
surrogate and to do this one of the
approaches that we follow is the
so-called projection based parametric
reduction and I'm going to exemplify
this on a benchmark that we tried to put
out for the community
um it should be that this QR code
hopefully still works this is this would
take you to the page where this
Benchmark is defined of course we're in
the civil engineering so our Benchmark
is a common civil structure it's a frame
which however features non-linear joints
so each one of these links are described
by a hysterectic model it's actually a
book one type of model which means that
the response of the system to earthquake
loading which is a typical excitation
for the analysis of these structures is
non-linear and what we would like to do
here is to produce a parametric model so
I reduced all their models that can run
for different configurations of this
system meaning for different properties
of the hysteretic model of this
non-linear joints but also for different
characteristics of the input forcing the
earthquake which can come at different
amplitudes and with different spectral
contents so to try and do this the first
thing we have to do is to actually
parameterize our input because we need
also the input to be something that can
form a part of our defining the defining
parameters of our model
and it turns out that for earthquake
sequences it is possible to actually
parameterize this and this was shown in
the work of Verizon in the caregion and
we followed that work and essentially
took real instances of earthquakes from
the pure strong motion database where
more than 2 000 actual earthquake time
sequences have been recorded and we
broke them down into parameters that
essentially have to do with the spectral
and temporal characteristics of the
earthquake how the amplitude evolves
over time and what is the spectral
content of the earthquake sequence and
by breaking them down into these
parameters we can actually now take a
specific earthquake time series
represented with these parameters that
now form part of the definition of our
problem
but perhaps the more difficult aspect
here is to see how to reduce the
non-linear system itself
so okay we parameterize the input uh the
load but we also wish to execute our
simulation for different characteristics
of our frame maybe different elastic
characteristic but also hysteretic uh
properties and so to do this in
affordable computational time we follow
a projection based approach where the
original non-linear Dynamic equation of
the problem which is an ordinary
differential equation is brought down
into a much smaller Dimension a
dimension r that is Affordable to
compute and the key to doing this is to
construct or to multiply our original
equation with this reduction basis which
is basically like a Larkin projection
basis all this is
in simple words is basically a matrix
that we assemble by having several
simulations we call them snapshots of
the original full order model and by
executing a singular value decomposition
on those several time series it is
possible to extract this gallerykin
projection basis essentially a matrix
again of main modes that govern the
response of the non-linear system and by
pre and post multiplying with this
Matrix we end up in this reduced still
non-linear equation which is also a
parametric it has a parametric
dependence now what this means is
because parametric the parametric
dependence exists is that we have to
compute these bases in different regions
of our parametric space and there's
different ways that people approach this
problem different
groups or different works in the
literature approach the problem one of
the more popular ones is to create
clusters in the parametric space and
just compute these basis for snapshots
within that cluster what is not so nice
about this approach or at least bothered
me was the fact that it's not a smooth
dependence relationship so in an effort
to develop something like this we have
proposed this coefficient Matrix
interpolation scheme where the reduced
order
matrices are produced through a double
projection
first a projection to have the local
basis a second projection to extract a
coefficient dependence of these local
bases on our on a global uh basis
coefficient on a global basis Matrix and
the connection between the two is
actually enforced through an autoencoder
the tool that we used previously for
reduction is now used for expressing
this dependence relationship giving us
basis matrices on the on by inputting
specific sets of our parametric space
what does this mean so given the problem
of our frame for different parameters of
the load of the earthquake but also
different parameters of the
configuration of the frame we can
produce through this conditioning this
conditional variation a lot of encoder
the coefficient Vector which when
multiplied with a global basis Matrix
that I can generate from my snapshots my
original simulations will give me
targeted local basis that will Define
the new reduced equation of the problem
that I need to solve and so this is the
way in which we tackle this problem
which gave us really as at least for
this kind of an application an edge we
can compute with higher accuracy but
also quite interestingly uh
uh some co-accelerated computational
time but more importantly for us we can
also generate confidence intervals for
our prediction and what empowers us to
produce this confidence intervals is the
fact that we use a variational
autoencoder which is on its own a
sampling approach so our latent space is
no longer a deterministic space but it's
actually a distribution which allows us
to generate the samples that can then
create this prediction which is
stochastic in nature and something
that's important to give also a
confidence in the prediction that we
furnish which is at the end of the day
always an approximation so this is our
attempt to reduction and now I would
like to take a portion of the talk to
discuss the connection with data in real
time
so we know we can reduce our modems but
how do we bring the data into play and
one way to do this at least one way that
we have long worked for in our group is
to do it through Bayesian Bayesian
filtering formulations
how does this work well we still have
this equation of the Dynamics which
requires a model of the system possibly
a reduced order model as I mentioned
before but We additionally have an
observation equation these are the few
and sparse measurements that we extract
from the system it's not only degrees of
freedom but the ones that we have the
luxury to instrument and draw
information from now the combination of
the model in the data can be achieved by
using evasion logic which is really a
two-step logic first we predict the
response of our system at the next point
in time by using the equation of our
system
which was essentially
this
state space formulation even if it's a
non-linear State space formulation and
the second step is to update our
estimation on the basis of the
discrepancy between what we predict and
what we measure at those sparse
locations and these are represented here
through the likelihood and the prior
which which are basically combined
through the Bayesian logic to give us a
posterior estimate of the response of
the system at the next point in time a
posterior that is conditioned on the
data that we collect but also in the
physics which is imprinted on the models
on the equations that Define the
likelihood and the prior
so here's how this works for non-linear
systems it is not easy to use linear
formulations like the Kalman filter for
those who are familiar with these
specific formulations instead we have to
relax a bit or simulation and we use
approximations that are based on samples
so assume you have a dynamic system at a
given point in time it's state its
response is approximated with sampling
which tries to represent the probability
that our system is at a given
displacement and velocity configuration
at that point in time we have an
equation a state equation usually which
can be a non-linear reduced order model
that can tell us what is the response of
our system at the next point in time
this would be what we call our prior and
then we also have measurements which can
give us a sense of how far what we
predict is from the reality and this is
uh then
weighed in through Bayes theorem to give
us the posterior estimate of the
response of the system and all of this
is achieved through the use of reduced
ordered models and because of this it
can be done in real time for different
types of tasks of Interest including
control and Diagnostics now in our group
we have worked as for a long time
actually essentially since the end of my
PhD on schemes that are using this
patient logic Force State estimation
meaning the response of the system joint
State and parameter estimation so we can
also actually infer the parameter the
parameters of the system when these are
assumed as unknowns or input State
estimation because I mentioned that the
inputs and the loads are hardly ever
precisely measured so there is a way to
use this framework to also assess the
loads or to assess everything everywhere
all at once which is everything the
input the state and the parameter of the
system of course given specific
properties are respected because this
can be a very ill problem otherwise
uh so let me show you an example of how
this can work and to do this I will use
a simulated case study which is from one
of our projects that was on Aerospace
structures and there the idea was to use
a few sensors that could be mounted for
example on the fuselage and understand
what is the response of the system first
of all in non-measured locations so so
that we get a fully filled image of how
the structure response but to also
possibly detect the presence of faults
and defects in these thin cell
structures usually come in the form of
cracking which could be in multiple
locations and so to do this we will use
physics and the physics we use in our
group is an extended finite element
approach which is particularly suited
for fracture but it's not real time so
we will have to also use the reduced
order modeling approach that I mentioned
before
but where a challenge exists in our
Bringing Down the equations of the
problem from this full Dimension to A
reduced Dimension because now in order
to extract these modes of the system it
is important for us to have
a configuration of the system That
Remains the Same under different
parametric configurations and here's the
problem when a parameter of the system
is a crack which can have different
locations if I am to use different
meshes or even the x-frame approach
which is particularly adapting keeping
the same mesh but still adding the
degrees of freedom suddenly if the
location of the crack changes I would
not be able to have the same type of
reference for my system I would not be
able to produce modes that much or make
sense because of these crack parameters
I would have a non-smooth problem which
however we try to tackle by bringing
back our knowledge from physics and
mechanics so we used a sort of trick we
used mesh morphing where we take the
original curved configuration first we
map it into a flat mesh and we assume
that we have a reference crack somewhere
located conveniently within the main
body of the object which we then distort
we basically distort the mesh using
modifying the universe distance waiting
which allows us to bring the original
crack into a new location so we can then
represent a new crack within our space
but using the exact same nodes and the
numbering remaining the same which means
that I can then also use this logic of
reduction by referring to the same node
number so now I am able to use the
reduced order model that I explained
before to approximate the dynamic
response of a cracked curved surface and
I can do it in real time which is
actually faster than this video exactly
for us and this means that I can also
feed the measurements that I have in the
bedroom logic that I showed before
together with this reduced model and
indeed this is what we do there is
actually even a further step of
complexity here because the input in
this kind of system is certainly not
measured so I have to operate with a
filter that can tackle
unknown inputs and this type of Fleet
there are many such filters here we use
an augmented Kalman filter to do this
and in fact we use a bank parallel
installations of this filter so that we
can actually at the same time infer not
only the response of the system but also
the parameters of the system which
include the location of the crack which
is the defect we're trying to identify
this shows you the convergence of our
algorithm as we start from random
locations and assumptions of faults and
their positions at time zero and slowly
as the estimation progresses we have
convergence to the drum location of
these fonts and quite importantly for us
we also have the possibility to estimate
the response of the system in
non-measured locations these green
locations are not sensed so we can
actually quite fairly it's a simulated
problem so here maybe it's a bit easier
but we can show that we can reproduce
the response of the system and in fact
we can do it at a fraction of the time
that is required even by improved
solvers and accelerated models so in 22
seconds would be the best case scenario
for a FM based approach Point 12 seconds
is what the surrogate here can achieve
um there is a further complexity here
that I'm not going to go into the into
details of so I'd rather just keep this
for later in case there is interest for
this it's how we would tackle uh further
challenges relating to input
so let me see if I can skip this
uh because it seems a bit stuck
ah there we go so what I would like to
discuss here finally is the aspect of
model discrepancy because what I showed
before actually is very nice and I will
show that it works well on simulated
data but what happens in real cases is
that additionally to uncertain inputs
and uncertain parameters of our models
we also have model mismatch what we call
model form uncertainty in other words we
can never promise that our physics is
good enough to capture the full
phenomenon of what we observe and to
tackle this we have been working with
our group in Singapore as well with but
primarily with this group on the
development of physics enhanced as we
call it or physics infused learning and
we have been playing with schemes that
are so-called physics guided schemes
where the physics comes through explicit
incorporation of equations into the
problem physics encoded schemes where we
try to force the neural network
architecture to respect the physics of
the problem for example we use a
neurologies to reflect systems that form
ordinary differential equations or
physics informed schemes where the
infusion of the physics is a bit more
loose but it tries to bring in Concepts
like hamiltonian principles symplectic
integration that would go well with
those principles
or physics informed neural networks
where again in the likelihood function
we try to demand the satisfaction of
specific governing equations
so we try to actually organize the
different tools that exist in the
Spectrum which reflects the use of
physics versus the use of data so the
Bayesian filtering scheme that I
mentioned earlier tends to use a lot of
physics but requires less data because
it assumes a good knowledge of the
physics that's underlying the problem
but as we go into
more physics agnostic representations
we'll try to We tend to rely more
heavily on the data or we can try to
merge the two into something that is a
compromise and that's what I would like
to show here as a final application an
application which we use for drive-by
monitoring this is basically the
assessment of traversed infrastructure
the roads or Railways by trains or cars
where the sensors are mounted on the
vehicles the collected information is
vibration and we try to assess the
condition of the infrastructure itself
we do this by using these models that
are in the in between or gray zone of
that Spectrum where we have some
knowledge of the physics but it's not
perfect and we we add a learning model
that is there to take on the portion of
the physics that we simply do not know
or is at least hidden to us
by superimposing these terms
and learning a combination of the two
we're able to make up for this model for
mismatch but we're also able to bias
what would have been a purely Black Box
model by the partial physics that we
know it's in which operates beneficially
for our system here's a simple example
this is the case uh actually let me not
go into the details of this but let me
rather show you this application the
simple example for the case of drive by
monitoring where we're trying to
understand the roughness of the road
surface and where we fuse a model of the
vehicle uh at least a partial model of
the vehicle that tries to approximate it
plus a portion that is a learning term a
deep learning term that tries to make up
for the unknown or the model form
discrepancy and there is actually a
logic a waiting factor that is the
optional optimal combination of the two
this is actually not something that the
user Tunes this is just forced here to
show the point it's something that is
learned by the framework and that allows
us to get the best of both worlds we
have actually also experimentally
validated this logic because I'm close
to the end I will not show you the
experimental validation I will just like
to go to this sort of leave you with
what we what I think is next after this
kind of fusion uh which is the last
portion of the chain that I showed in
the beginning and that was about
handling uh systems of systems and here
is such an example at the ecosystem
level here we try to harness information
for wind farms
but we're trying to do it in a way that
can allow for transfer of knowledge so
we have models first of all of uh Wind
Farm layouts where we try to uh which we
try to approximate using a graph
representation we consider a graph
representation as possibly the most
comfortable representation for
representing systems that have a
geometric distribution this is true not
only for structures that admit a mesh
but also for wind turbines which are
individual entities distributed within a
farm and by training such graph neural
network based models we're able to train
on specific configurations on which we
have data or simulated but even real
data and then we try to simulate systems
of new and unseen geometric
configurations purely as forward
simulations to produce quantities of
interest and we show that it is possible
to produce and with such quantities of
the interest like the power produce the
turbulence intensity that is experienced
the damage equivalent load on the basis
of few inputs like the mean wind field
conditions in the farm and training on
different separate farm geometries and
the power of such a transfer lies in the
exploitation of the principle of graphs
and this is what we would like to use
therefore for the so-called upper
population based shm approach where we
don't just care about the individual
structure but the Assembly of these
structures uh
I would like to close with this this
sort of a holistic view of the framework
we would like to put in place which
takes us from exploitation of data the
fusion of this data with physics to
extract Hybrid models that are more
informative offer this information to
the experts and stakeholders for
decision support and then augment this
kind of
management to the level of fields and
ecosystems of different types of
structures
so I think this is a good slide to close
since I'm very close to the end
and ask for any questions
that you have on this sort of chain that
I tried to explain thank you thank you
so much I mean it sounds like a you have
a lot more to present uh actually it
feels like we have to invite you one
more time no I think I
try so I think I took a bit more time
than I planned and I'm sorry for this
gives an overview of what we have yeah
yeah I mean we saw the cine picture of a
lot of stuff but I you know every single
snippet was pretty uh interesting and
exciting uh I can see I I can see why
you are so excited about your project
um just by listening to your talk that
was awesome all right let's have a q a
session if you have any questions please
um you know unmute yourself and ask
questions
[Music]
um
yeah go ahead hi Lenny good to see you
in this context
yeah it's nice to see you hi
um I mean it was very very detailed
presentation I have it a high level
question for you because all of us
through the world the the words digital
twin around and uh if you if you were to
Define it yourself what would you say it
is uh well you know in the context of
you know the digital twin has come to
grow into something that is exploited by
many different disciplines I love in
this sense I think it can also have many
different meanings I mean it's different
for beam right the building information
modeling made where it's more of an
instantiation of a system uh for
monitoring however it is extremely
important for this twin to be
interactive and continuously updated
which means that we sort of have to have
this sort of disclosed Loop which allows
us to always understand the condition of
the system and give it makes it possible
for us to intervene and it's very
similar in control and I know that you
know you know probably you share the
opinion from your applications if you
wish to be able to interact with the
system it cannot be without having this
constant supervision so it a twin for me
something that has a closed-loop
communication with the actual physical
system and that's not always the case
and maybe it's fine but in our context
this is what it should be
yeah that that makes sense I think yeah
I think context defines it and and
everybody's stealing it for the purpose
of marketing
and I really like your last slide and I
will steal it
um and then sure
everything is connected I think that's
that's the essence of it thank you
beautiful talk thank you well well
related to the beautiful slide I'm Eleni
would you mind sharing your slide yeah
yeah let me do that again I did it
because I couldn't see the audience
otherwise but maybe I can
uh
um I have to do full screen is it
visible now wrong yeah awesome well I I
I see that and that's just the last
slide but I see
um many other slides were pretty
beautiful
all right sounds good uh there's a
question in chat room by Peter well um
instead of me asking maybe Peter do you
want to unmute yourself and ask ask that
question yourself or do you want me to
video for you
oh okay I have to stop the screen share
I think again yeah I I can read it for
you Peter has a mic issue um is the
cultural relationship between inputs and
outputs of the interest always clear or
do you sometimes have to perform
additional data analysis to establish
the causality prior to the development
of a physical model yeah this is a very
good question
because as I mentioned at one point of
the presentation it's very easy to end
up with an early post problem when you
when we claim that you know there are
many things that we do not know
including uh the actual loading source
of the dynamic system when this is
unknown things become quite difficult so
there are some formal checks when we try
to impose a model structure we should
first check if our model is observable
and we should check the detectability
somehow of the system
um which means that which is always
easier to do with linear systems but you
can also do with non-linear systems so
this is an important check to try and do
formally when you try to put a model
into the loop for for purely data driven
representations another check that has
to be done because oftentimes we try to
extract the purely data driven model is
the parsimony of the
representation that we extract you know
so this this checks are important and
should be in place in order to have a
representation that is really performant
otherwise it could be that you have
overfeeding that you have
non-convergence and that you can you
have instability and actually something
that is not usable at the end of the day
totally agree some sort of
pre-processing of the data and make it
you know quality data it's
um the model the model as well has to be
checked and it has to be something that
is in a position to operate with the
inputs that we have in hand yeah because
here we're not you know since our
interest is to view some sort of model
into the representation it also has to
be configured in an appropriate way
right right
yeah so nothing is perfectly automatic
some some knowledge has to be injected
uh
Peter also asked another question
um Are there specific tools you use to
establish this like yes
from the side of the model is more on
observability as I mentioned before is
the parsimony of these models but then
when you're talking about the data it is
uh indeed aspects that have to do with
the correlations of the driving inputs
um and different you know different
checks that could guarantee the
sufficiency sample of the data for
describing the problem at hand there's
also tests that we do to understand how
linear or non-linear problem is for
example through understanding through
using coherence functions or other types
of input output relationship checks or
statistical checks and
awesome that Define the nature of the
problem
all right thank you Eleni um
um is there any other question
please unmute and
ask your question
well I mean
um I have many questions but um you know
you know respecting the time
um I guess I can email you uh separately
yes I do I do I can show my email there
for I think I may have it on one of our
last slides so this is an image of our
group it also contains my email where
you can reach me with any
comments feedback or also intentions for
collaboration that would be very welcome
it's one of the nice outcomes of stocks
so exactly
um and I do myself I see that there are
a couple of topics we can collaborate so
I'm very excited that would be awesome
I'll wait to hear from you then from
others who may be interested yeah yeah
definitely you will hear from us for
sure all right with that I guess we can
um you know thank our speaker for the
wonderful talk and interesting
presentations and yeah but thank you so
much
no thank you it was my pleasure so I
hope to get to see you again soon yeah
yeah
thank you so much
have a nice day